now the mayor of London has announced
that London's ultra low emission Zone
otherwise known as Euless is going to be
expanded from August next year the
changes will mean that drivers of older
cars who enter the greater London
Authority boundary will face a daily fee
of 12 pounds 50 for using London's roads
so I'm pleased to say the mayor of
London City Khan joins us now from East
London now good afternoon to you Mr
Connor just explain a little bit more if
you will in a bit more detail about what
is going to be in place in August
uh good to join you listen it wasn't a
easy decision it was a tough decision
but it's the right decision here in our
great City every year there are more
than 4 000 premature deaths directly
attributable
to air pollution to the air we breathe
that's an invisible killer you can't see
the nitrogen dark side and the
particular matter but it leads to
children having stunted lungs forever
and adults with a whole host of health
issue from asthma to dementia from
cancer to heart disease and we've seen
the world leading Ultra emission Zone
being transformative in Central and in
London reducing by half the toxic air in
central London by further 20 in in
London I think the right to breathe
clean air is surely a right for everyone
in London and that's why from next
August with the support of a massive 110
million pounds Scrappy scheme will be
expanding you less so all londoners can
breathe cleaner air so 12 pounds 50 for
those uh with certain types of vehicle
and then that's on top of the congestion
charge
so at the moment actually across the
Euless area more than 94 of vehicles are
now compliant it used to be only 39 of
vehicles so what our policies leading to
is a change in Behavior fewer
non-compliant vehicles and an
improvement in air but because I
recognize that if you're a Lincoln
family if you're a small business if
you're a charity if you're a disabled
Londoner you maybe try driving a
pollution vehicle and need help I've
also announced today a massive Scrappy
scheme 110 million pounds which also
enables you to retrofit your vehicle if
you want to do so if you can't make the
option of changing from your car to a
cleaner vehicle another thing we've
announced today is the biggest expansion
of new bus routes ever in outer London
an additional million kilometers of new
bus routes but but what I'm getting out
Mr Khan is this is going to be very
expensive isn't it for some people whose
Vehicles don't comply and they're
driving into London and they're going to
get clobbered with the congestion charge
and the Euless charge now at a time the
worst cost of living crisis in living
memory many people can't afford their
heating or indeed food
there's only a cost if your vehicle is
non-compliant that's why we've got the
scrappy skin but look I accept that the
politically expedient decision would
have been to Kick the Can down the road
but I think the cost of inaction we've
seen far away the costs of action I
think Public Health trumps political
experiences but to support families to
support businesses during the cost of
living crisis we have the scrappy scheme
which will be helping people make the
transition a just transition this so
what what do you hope to raise from
there so what have you raised already
from you less charges and what do you
hope to raise by expanding it
well actually the cost of Euros in the
first few years outweighs the money you
bring in but any net proceeds we make
any every penny that it's a net proceeds
in the Surplus is going to be invested
in public transport it's really
important that we invest in public
transport simply not possible for us to
encourage people to move away from
Vehicles unless we can make walk-in
cycling and public transport a better
alternative so just to reassure those
that still will be driving and
non-compliant vehicles by the way they
themselves are breathing in the poison
as well as others every penny raised net
will be invested in public transport but
many people and there have been various
polls I know that you disagree with some
of them but there have been a number of
polls which show that the majority of
londoners don't agree with this
expansion of Euless and they say that
it's all about Revenue raising uh
instead of being about public health
what do you say to that
one of the most comprehensive poll
showed that actually more than double a
London has supported the expansion that
are against it but actually here's the
point in the 1950s when the government
took a brave decision to pass the Clean
Air Act and basically ban power stations
from Central London there was also
opposition uh to that when I was in
Parliament and I voted to ban smoking in
public places massive opposition uh to
that as well when I first introduced the
ultra emission Zone there was opposition
to that initially but actually the
effects had been transformative of the
Clean Air Act Banning smoking in public
spaces and the ultra low emission Zone
in fact experts say the best way the
quickest way to clean up the air in our
city is expanding euros and in fact
cities across the globe including in our
country are speaking to us on a daily
basis asking us how they can do the same